six o'clock here on a thursday morning
we start though with breaking news metro
police investigating a murder at umc our
mary jane bellezza is at the scene with
the very latest or i'm sorry at metro's
headquarters there was some information
mary jane what happened here
yeah heather and john good morning we
just got done with the briefing by metro
police they're still investigating the
stabbing at umc hospital where two
people were stabbed the suspect a man
left his room and stabbed a man who died
from his injuries that suspect then left
and went to step another patient in a
hospital bed located in the hallway
thankfully that patient was able to
escape towards the exit doors along with
the charge nurse in that area security
in the hospital responded to the scene
and the suspect went back to his room
and correctional officers in the
hospital on an unrelated call also
responded to that area
they re heard the commotion and heard
their call that there was a person with
a knife stabbing somebody inside the
hospital they quickly responded they
made entry into that area the hospital
where they located the suspect in his
room and they were able to take him into
custody without incident
now what we know is that the suspect is
a male in his 40s and the suspect and
the victims were in the psychiatric area
of the hospital metro police are still
currently investigating how that suspect
got a knife and they do tell me that
that area of the hospital where this
incident took place is now secure
reporting live mary jane valeza live
local now